[Music]
for our next segment of today's show i
would like hey amber uh sorry to
interrupt
can we stop the show for a second oh
sure
what's going on rick well we've been
looking at our ratings for the show and
the network is worried because
your numbers are down in certain
demographics
well what demographic people that live
in california
california no no really
yup california justice and watch it for
some reason oh that's upsetting
i mean i thought we were making a show
that appealed to everyone
we do have a solution though if you're
open to it of course
anything for the show great roll it
coming to you from 30 rockefeller plaza
in new york city is
amber ruffin
cowabunga everybody i'm amber ruffin and
this is my co-host
terry davis how are you tarek i'm doing
hella good
that's so sick
okay uh well we've got a very dank show
for you tonight
amber uh so sorry we're gonna have to
stop down for a second again
okay that's great because i don't think
this is working oh it's not
our ratings are down again but this time
it's the teens
that seems fine i mean are we even
making a show for teens
no but we could be so we've got some
suggestions
i mean if you think there's something we
can do about that sure
i do roll it
[Music]
coming to you from like 30 rockefeller
plaza cause
it's the amber ruffin show
what's good rough riders i'm amber
ruffin but you can call me
big rough what no you cannot
this is my co-his-old tarik what's good
t-bone
i'm lit af cis and that's the t
damn daniel there is no way this is how
teens speak who wrote this
i did this is exactly how my nephew
talks
but actually we do have to stop again oh
god what now
nothing big you're doing great but now
the numbers are down with
conspiracy theories what how do we even
measure that
and why would we want conspiracy
theorists to watch
look it's a huge demographic you can't
have a hit show nowadays without
appealing to people who think
the earth is round oh fine wait
what
[Applause]
[Music]
coming to you from somewhere that's none
of your business it's
the amber ruffin show good evening
everybody
or is it my name's amber ruffin sure it
is
and this is the amber ruffin show that's
what they want you to believe
okay this is crazy can you really expect
us to make a good
show if we're changing it all the time
of course
that's how showbiz works we're just
making small changes for a wider appeal
yeah so who are these binoculars
appealing to
that's for the bird watchers demo okay
so what about this malted milkshake
that's for the white people that wish
they were born in the 50s okay well
what's this framed
photo of you for that's for the producer
rick demo
i don't watch the show you know there's
nothing on there for me
what you don't watch the show rick
dang this is nuts i think we should make
the show we want to make
and then just trust it'll find an
audience otherwise it's not the amber
ruffian show it's
the californian teen conspiracy theorist
show
that is that sounds like a great show
but you're probably right
all these changes are taking our core
audience anyway
who's our core audience nice people the
ages between 15 and 65 who are not
serial killers
okay yeah let's go back to doing a show
for them
[Music]
[Applause]
you